[Musica]
fin dall'età di 16 17 anni avrei voluto
essere diversa Non perché non mi
piacessi Ma perché la società mi faceva
sentire sbagliata avrei voluto avere la
pelle bianca gli occhi azzurri i capelli
biondi e le lentiggini quello perché mi
piacevano e invece come potete vedere ho
la pelle nera non ho gli occhi azzurri i
capelli quelli non li potete vedere e
ancora non ho le lentiggini
e in casa Scusa mamma dovevamo
assolutamente parlare quattro lingue
diverse perché era importante sapere le
lingue e per me vacanza voleva dire
prendere un aereo e andare dall'altra
parte del mondo e tornare nel paese di
origine dei miei genitori non che non mi
piacesse però a volte avrei voluto
andare in qualche località balneare qui
nel bel paese
poi è arrivata l'età dell'università
biotecnologie e la necessità come tanti
universitari di trovare un lavoretto per
arrotondare Ecco che mi si presenta la
possibilità di diventare Mediatrice
linguistica culturale richiedevano
quattro lingue o Grazie mamma e
finalmente potevo usare quelle lingue
che tanto Yahoo per guadagnare
Incomincio a capire una cosa che in
realtà la mia religione le mie
differenze in realtà erano un valore
aggiunto capisco che posso diventare un
punto un ponte tra Paesi diversi
capisco anche un'altra cosa
incomincio a frequentare ospedali
Aziende Sanitarie Locali e capisco che
voglio diventare la Flores Nine di
Brescia dai senza presunzione
un infermiera bene Ora sono veramente un
infermiera e voglio raccontarvi qualche
aneddoto che succede in una corsia di
ospedale
infermiera infermiera le pastiglie che
mi ha dato il dottore per le emorroidi
non funzionano pastiglie ma non erano
supposte Sì sì le prendo ogni sera prima
di andare a dormire ma queste emorroidi
non vogliono andarsene guardi l'orario
giusto però non vanno prese per bocca ma
bensì e ci siamo capiti Questa è una
true story una storia vera e di storia
così ne succedono tante quante volte vi
è capitato di non sentirvi bene e di
fare una cosa che facciamo tutti aprire
il telefono e guardare su Google Dai vi
vedo e farsi diagnosi diagnosi A volte
anche pesanti A volte questo atto
apparentemente superficiale può creare
dei problemi perché se non si hanno gli
strumenti giusti per interpretare le
informazioni si rischia di fare dei
grossi errori ma che cosa vuol dire
avere gli strumenti per effettuare
scelte di salute
vuol dire avere Health literacy ossia
la Health di terracy ossia
l'alfabetizzazione sanitaria viene
definita dall'organizzazione Mondiale
della sanità come il raggiungimento di
un livello di conoscenza abilità
personali e fiducia nell'agire per
migliorare la salute personale e
comunitaria modificando gli stili di
vita personali e le condizioni di vita
delle persone tante parole ma in soldoni
vuol dire riuscire a fare delle scelte
di salute in modo consapevoli
consapevolezza
sanitaria sarà uno dei concetti della
nostra chiacchierata che cosa vuol dire
capacità di acquisire comprendere e
saper utilizzare informazioni per la
propria salute
consapevolezza di chi e di cosa vi
starete chiedendo penserete la
consapevolezza dell'assistito è invece
no la consapevolezza deve essere sia
dell'assistito ma anche dell'operatore
sanitario in modo da effettuare delle
scelte di salute consapevoli salute
un termine che negli ultimi due anni
Abbiamo sentito tante volte un termine
che quando stiamo bene Ce ne scordiamo
Invece quando stiamo male ce ne
ricordiamo salute prima di tutto È un
diritto fondamentale garantito dalla
nostra Costituzione e in quanto tale
abbiamo tutti l'obbligo di far sì che
sia fruibile a tutti
la mancanza di un'alfabetizzazione
sanitaria e causa pensate del 26% della
spesa sanitaria Che cosa vuol dire
questo vuol dire che dobbiamo cercare di
fare azioni di prevenzione educazione
monitoraggio dei nostri pazienti
In poche parole una buona
alfabetizzazione sanitaria non è solo
una conquista Umanitaria ma anche una
conquista monetaria ve lo dirò in modo
forse anche un po' Brutale meno ammalati
più soldi
numeri invisibili
l'organizzazione Mondiale della sanità
parla di numeri invisibili ossia quelle
persone che sono affette da malattie
croniche non sessualmente trasmissibili
quelle malattie che purtroppo sono causa
di tantissimi decessi nel mondo pensate
le malattie croniche sono causa del 70%
dei decessi nel mondo e oltre il 90% dei
decessi nel nostro paese
provate a pensare
a quanto a volte sia difficile
comprendere le informazioni di salute
per una persona in questo caso autoctona
italiana provate ad immaginare di essere
persone che vengono dall'altra parte del
mondo che hanno usi e costumi diversi
che non conoscono il sistema sanitario
non necessariamente perché non hanno una
buona anfatizzazione ma perché forse non
hanno mai avuto la possibilità di
accedere a un ospedale in modo gratuito
di accedere a una farmacia e acquistare
dei farmaci
e provate a pensare se oltre il problema
della Health di terracy abbiamo anche
quello della digitalizzazione sanitaria
Ecco che il problema sembri ingigantisce
infatti la Health literacy e la Health
Take information devono andare di pari
passo
come
con uno strumento molto semplice alla
portata di tutti che avete delle vostre
tasche o nelle vostre borse lo
smartphone Infatti alfabetizzazione
sanitaria fa rima con semplicità bisogna
essere semplici e dimostrato dalla
letteratura sanitaria e anche
dall'esperienza clinica che le persone i
cittadini hanno una sfiducia nel
servizio sanitario perché gli operatori
sanitari medici infermieri utilizzano
termini troppo lontani e termini troppo
tecnici
Infatti è importante che il mondo
sanitario comprenda che trasmettere
l'informazione non è solo
interpretariato ma anche mediazione
mediazione culturale mediazione socio
culturale
Ecco che ho progettato un progetto che
si chiama Health in Tech una piattaforma
digitale semplice intuitiva dove la
frase cardine è sempre connessi Infatti
i pazienti è al centro di questo sistema
in poche parole il paziente è connesso
all'operatore sanitario l'operatore
sanitario è connesso al paziente I
servizi sono connessi al paziente
creando un ponte tra territorio e
ospedale e territorio
provate a pensare a quante volte siete
andati dal medico e non avete capito
cosa vi sta dicendo e forse per vergogna
o per paura o semplicemente perché in
quel momento non vi siete resi conto non
l'avete chiesto non avete fatto domande
invece provate a pensare di andare dal
medico che vi spiega che cosa avete e
attraverso dei supporti multimediali vi
fa comprendere che cosa vuol dire la
vostra malattia le conseguenze di questa
malattia e cerca di educarvi su come
evitare determinate problematiche
provate a pensare a quando dovete
adottare una dieta particolare e andate
dall'operatore sanitario vi fa vedere
grazie a delle infografiche ciò che
potete mangiare o non mangiare anche dei
vostri piatti tipici del paese d'origine
E queste infografiche sono semplicemente
salvabili sul vostro smartphone e poi
quando andate a fare la spesa TAC TAC Le
guardate
Questa è la piattaforma una piattaforma
che mantiene connessi tutti tutti questi
schemi che molto spesso sono lontani in
questo modo garantiamo l'aderenza
terapeutica del paziente con i servizi
diagnostici in modo che sia sempre più
consapevole e al centro del sistema un
altro esempio il paziente e a casa e
comodamente si rileva la glicemia questo
dato viene trasmesso sulla piattaforma e
nel ambulatorio infermieristico
l'infermiere Comodamente seduto davanti
al computer vede i dati e capisce se i
range della glicemia sono Corretti e in
caso di un problema o di un valore non
corretto semplicemente prende la
piattaforma manda un messaggio o chiede
al paziente il perché non abbia rilevato
la glicemia tutto questo coadiuvato da
un team di mediatori linguistici
linguistico culturali e etno clinico che
avranno il compito di facilitare e
creare sempre più un ponte tra mondi
diversi
Ecco questa è la Health Take in infatti
la Digital digitalizzazione sanitaria e
l'alfabetizzazione sanitaria devono
diventare sempre più pilastri importanti
del nostro Welfare sanitario
Non possiamo pensare a una società
multiculturale e multietnica senza
questi due importanti principi Infatti
sono facce della stessa medaglia
se vogliamo veramente garantire il
diritto di Salute a tutti e ora che
tutti insieme cittadini operatori
sanitari sistema sanitario si mettano
insieme affinché la salute possa essere
fruibile per tutti perché la salute è un
diritto di tutti per tutti
ora siete pronti a diventare Help Tech
I'm in and you perché la salute passa
prima di tutto dall'informazione
[Applauso]